so Charlie what's your greatest fear
well Charlie I'd have to say the
microsphere is death oh is that is that
what you talk about yeah yeah it is
okay I'll leave it to it's not a
particularly original fear um sorry
about that but you know that's not it's
already how it works is it you don't
pick the most interesting thing that I'm
afraid of guacamole well is so quirky
you and yet no I just I'm just afraid of
what I'm afraid of
we're sorry like guacamole if you are
genuinely afraid of guacamole by the way
I'm sorry if for making light of your
fears but if you are afraid of guacamole
it's not the worst thing in the world
because you can always just let you know
not go to Mexican restaurants whack
Amole isn't inevitable it's not gonna
take you in the night I don't I don't
know why the idea of a guacamole Grim
Reaper is so funny to me it just is but
death nobody else thinks that is as
funny as I do I'm sure of it but death
right death is inevitable
there's nothing I can do about the fact
that one day I'm gonna die it would be
useful if I believed in any kind of
afterlife I don't so my fate I think is
gonna be the the big nothing the big
black dark void of no consciousness of
no anything and that is what terrifies
me that void is the only thing in my
life at the moment that really makes me
want to poo my pants
given that I can't really help how I
feel what do I do honestly the first
thing I go to is well you never know
technology these days in 20 or 30 years
we they could have done immortality we
could all live forever wouldn't that be
lovely no it wouldn't for one thing
earth is kind of reaching capacity
anyway right now and pretty sure of some
scientist invented immortality most
people would want a piece in that and I
think that might result in too many
humans which would be a big problem and
there's also the factor of at some point
the universe is going
and so you will die like you can't exist
if there's no place for you to exist in
after that I think well if I am gonna
die at least I can live forever in the
memories of the people who love me right
now even if you did the coolest thing
that anyone has ever done ever the
people who remember you they're going to
die as well
everyone is going to die no one is gonna
be around to remember anyone eventually
so oh then what makes me feel better
weirdly enough is thinking about my
funeral my fantasy funeral I'm aware of
the fact that this is not gonna happen
but ideally I kind of like my body to be
shot into the Sun I don't know I just
really like the idea of all my friends
and family you know sitting around
worrying back being somber my mum little
tear in her eye
I tied before my mum did oh but everyone
you know just hanging out in a graveyard
looking up at a giant rocket and then
seeing that rocket being shot into a
boiling hot ball of plasma that I would
just be awesome wouldn't it
realistically though what can you do
with a fear of death if there's one
thing I've learned about being scared
over the years given that I am youtube's
resident expert on the topic it's that
if you are afraid of something mean it
means that thing is pretty important and
what's important to me it's you know
it's obvious really it's living the
fullest and best life I possibly can
making the most of the time I have left
on this planet so that when I finally am
on my deathbed I can look back at
everything I've done and be like yeah
pretty good job well done charlie that's
it and then you know black void of
nothingness anyway huh that's what I'm
here about recently see you next week
whoa it's not gonna happen daven I'll be
around don't you worry about me you've
just had the almost imponderable joy of
watching Charlie is so cool like which
makes you like cool
[Applause]
so the fear is probably worse for me
Jesus I'm making another video about
something I'm scared of just let's just
get on with it shall we
what's your greatest fear charlie uh I
guess my favorite my um my favorite fear
my favorite fear my all-time favorite
fear